i'm here with Hartwig talbot the
director general of the ftth council
europe hard wait we're coming to the
conclusion of the 12th show it seems to
be a tremendous success what for you
have been some of the highlights yes the
fth conference here in vaasa was again a
huge event it's again reaching close to
3,000 participants which means we reach
the same size like Stockholm last year
and it makes it the biggest 5 of the
home related event in the world which of
course we as an f th Council a proud of
and so the highlights we had this year
in the conference was a real high level
lineup of speakers so we had a minister
another Secretary of State the
regulators the chair of barrick just in
the opening giving a very impressive
statements we had the European
Commission presenting their plans and
points of view and we had also in the
breakout sessions a lot of sea level CEO
people talking about their plans which
of course for us was a very big success
and on the other hand if you see the
people here talking to each other making
networking making a business I think we
reached again our goal to make this FTTH
conference the networking event for 500
home in Europe which that's what we hope
will give a strong push for 2015 in the
fiber market yes I actually had some
very good feedback about the workshops I
understand they were particularly well
attended indeed this was a successor
even were surprised off because we had
1,100 people already coming to the
workshops on the Tuesday on the first
day and this was a tremendous success
and the feedback also the content of the
workshops was very positive so that's
something i can already reveal we will
build on this and see how we can further
develop this concept i'm sure that will
be very well received based on this year
and obviously you've been with the
council many years now you know all
about FTTH but has there been anything
that surprised you this week yes there
was some surprises indeed I mr. council
d-did 10th year now so for me it's a bit
of an anniversary and that's the
relations acquire icing
to to see that there are sometimes
topics when which two years ago one year
ago nobody would have discussed suddenly
pop up in a lot of matters and this was
my surprise this conference that we had
topics like alternative mrs. models
structural separation meaning separation
of the network and the services and all
this kind of open access models no
longer only be discussed on a level of
small operators but really on a national
level like we had speakers from Ireland
here on local governmental levels which
I believe is a big change in the market
because this can have a huge impact on
the development of fiber in Europe if
suddenly there are changes in the way
fiber networks are perceived to be built
talking of the market you've obviously
announced all the latest statistics are
you pleased with the way things are
progressing yes and no as always because
of course we would love to see all of
Europe fiber eyes but and that's the
good news we are pleased in a way that
we have a fifty percent increase of
households connected to fibers so being
subscribers to services on a 50 to the
home of 50 to the building network so
between december 2013 in december 2014
in the European Union scale we came from
10 million to 15 million households
connected of course knowing the size of
the European Union there is still a long
way to go but the important message we
see is that it is getting now on the
market in a steady grow which is good
for us be not so nice thing on that one
is that it is mainly the fibrous
countries who simply continue to roll
out so countries like Sweden countries
like Portugal they are really strong or
the Nordic countries in its whole region
they continue rolling out its the good
message on this one is it means if a
fiber network is working then the people
like it and you get more and more
subscribers the bad side of it is that
the big economies in particular I always
need to say it is every year UK and
Germany they are still lagging behind I
don't want to make it to negative
because with this discussions around new
business models there is a lot happening
in Germany at least and I can already
tell you that if Germany continues this
way and having companies like da chi
class father who are really changing the
market at the moment they could at least
this one person threshold that we have
in our five already home global ranking
they could reach it during the year and
that would be of course a first step of
course it's one person so the other 99
need to follow them very soon talking of
the year ahead what's coming up for the
council what areas you're going to be
working on for the ftth Council 2015
will be a very important year on at the
brothel side because the young core
long-term investment plan talking about
300 billion of investments into
long-term infrastructure also is a
strong effect on fiber because 30 to 40
billion of this money could be available
for fiber projects and this is something
very as an FTTH council see a very
strong task to ensure that it is really
such an amount that is used and to avoid
that all the money is going into streets
in two railroads into a energy sector
like it happened with the connecting
Europe facility so for us we will work
very hard to the next months to make
sure there's a lot of money available
for for fiber networks and we really
hope that then 2016 when we have our
conference in luxembourg in February we
can already report yes mission is
completed we really had saved at least
30 billion of the Yonkers plan to be
invested into a fibre broadband networks
well we'll look forward to that thank
you very much for joining us thank you
so the ftth council europe event more
than 3,000 visitors another major
success and a big year ahead